all right novak djokovic ah yeah
oh yeah not allowed to go to to
australia because he notoriously is
refusing the vaccine okay and then he's
allowed into australia under special
conditions in order to play in the
tournament there what tournament is it
in australia australia jesus christ
he's allowed to play there yeah and then
as he lands there and he's in the hotel
then they decide oh actually there's an
issue with your visa you can't play yeah
and then and then he basically gets
deported out of australia no no no
they've changed today oh they changed it
again yeah they put them in to uh the
hotel hotel yeah um and then while he's
been in there i think it's day four yeah
uh then they were a judge
george
today but they still they're still
threatening to cancel his visas so i
looked into this what they're asking for
the reason he got denied is they didn't
have proper medical proof which he still
might be able to provide but i approve
of what he so he submitted a the reason
he could uh was allowed in is a medical
exemption which is i tested positive for
corona on december 16th and because you
can test positive for like a month out
countries that started doing this thing
were like look if you have a positive
corona test from two weeks to 90 days
you can come in you don't have to get
the negative test right because you know
you have the antibodies yeah yeah you're
safe you could just be testing positive
because that's what happened yeah so the
things that are suspicious are one he
already tested positive in june 2020 he
had his own tennis tournament maskless
him and a bunch of other players got
corona then he got it again announced it
again june 2021 then december he doesn't
say anything about getting coveted and
he submits a test from december 16th
and if that's true december 17th he went
to a public event where he got like a
stamp in serbia he went there maskless
took pictures with mad kids no mask on
so
either you were like
woefully negligent once you got the
positive test or you're lying about that
positive test on december 16th because
it's been more than six months or
whatever the deadline is if you go back
to your last june positive so you're
like i just do one from december who
cares
and another reporter said there's like a
qr code that he submitted and if you
went to that qr code until this morning
they changed it but it would say the
test result was negative
and then all of a sudden this morning on
that same website that same qr code the
test is positive wow so he's trying some
slick [ __ ] he's trying some slicks he's
about to get caught he's probably get
locked up because it's probably a
federal offense
to lie about yours i don't know how they
can prove it though if he said he got it
from like serbia apparently half the
less than half the country's vaccinated
they don't believe in this [ __ ]
that's where everybody was going
remember it was like the only place was
it croatia croatia
but uh that's what i think i think he's
trying to fake a positive test so he can
get around and this guy
i he got some like weird nutrition and
science beliefs i think he's been
anti-vaxx like period like yeah
he absolutely has yeah like in april of
2020 a month after corona he was like
i'm not getting a vaccine
we won't even know anything we're all
still freaking out remember april yeah
we're still freaking the [ __ ] out i
think he's completely anti-vaxxed he
said he found out he had a gluten
allergy because a nutritionist had him
hold bread in his left hand and against
his stomach and put his right hand out
and then when he let go of the bread the
right arm was harder to push down and he
was like that means i have a celiac
allergy i gave up gluten from that day i
guess guys he's a [ __ ] brilliant
tennis player maybe the best ever but
he's nuts and also he's an elite athlete
who's at the peak of his powers like
i've had two vaccines i've had the the
first and the second jab i didn't
particularly want them health anxiety
drives me mad i got the astrozenica one
two days later there was loads of
headlines like oh this might be causing
blood clots particularly in young men
that's like oh [ __ ] kicked me off didn't
get it i got my second job so that i
could come to new york the only reason i
got it yeah
he and
he's a tennis player he knows let's be
honest if he gets covered he will
probably be fine yeah so why risk it so
why risk it on top of all of that and
also this i think his name is alan
brazil right so there's a sports
commentator in england he does like a
radio show called alan brazil he looks
he's enormous like he's he's this wide
he's constantly purple like he looks
like he's about to explode at all times
yeah and there's a i think the other day
he was closer to saying novak djokovic
is a threat to health services
it's like
you can't with a straight face say that
you're taking up so much more public
health money than anyone in the country
never mind a [ __ ] tennis player from
serbia yeah it's tricky man i think if
you can't prove the test is positive
though you gotta let them i mean the
test is um fake let him go i think you
have to let him yeah i have to let him
play yeah it's tricky i mean we were
talking about this earlier we weren't
here but like you know with the uh the
places that have universal health care
they're doing whatever they can to limit
the people in those beds and limit those
costs
and they're getting caught up in these
type of situations where he could go
there i think they shut down the city if
there's like one or two uh positive
tests right in australia don't they have
like these crazy strict rules right so
they're potentially letting somebody in
who could force the whole city to get
shut down they're trying to avoid that
this has become a massive point of
controversy because also he's got he's
tied for the grand slam record
and this is his best tournament he won
his first major here he says it's his
favorite tournament the australians
[ __ ] love him they're probably
frustrated because they've been so
locked up so he probably represents a
lot more to them than just some guy yeah
he should play a tennis court but also
they attacked his car
like he was driving from the hotel
reporters that were so [ __ ] geeked up
no i think i think they would have i saw
supporters attacking police
after throwing uh food and different
things oh really yeah police were
amazing people that i thought were like
protesting them but they were so uh my
understanding i thought my flag so it
was just like now that came out there
for him yeah oh wow okay maybe i got
that wrong they were so keyed up they
just didn't know how to [ __ ] act and
they like surrounded his car and he got
they were just like we're trying to get
this guy out of here yeah but yeah it's
become a whole like just test them now
hot button issue there yeah what's the
best stuff
just pcr test them now this is the
australia has their rules that you have
to be vaccinated or do a two-week
quarantine well well exactly yeah and
that's a tricky thing but here's the
thing i don't get it's like now we know
the vaccine doesn't do [ __ ]
for homeowners a negative test should be
good enough every day a negative test
should be the only thing we do true
because if you're doing for example go
to a bar in new york city if we know you
can get omicron
if you're vaccinated right what the [ __ ]
does that vaccine card do yeah how does
it keep anybody safe yeah maybe you get
i guess you could handle a little better
if you do but like the reality is you're
gonna [ __ ] get it so if you're gonna
take the negative test like let's say
you've got a negative test i don't want
to take a [ __ ] negative test every
single day i know they have to have some
system to like ensure the safety of the
employees sure but for in a tournament
like this the safest thing that they can
do for their people is pcr that
[ __ ] and you have the resources
like you can't do it at a restaurant
because you can't have every citizen
take a [ __ ] negative test every day
we don't have the infrastructure put him
in the detention center give him the pcr
if he's good let his ass if you got an
athlete worth hundreds of millions of
dollars you could test that [ __ ]
yeah i know there's people saying like
oh there shouldn't be any special
exemptions being made just because he's
a tennis player
yeah they should yeah yes yeah
if he's gonna make he's the two million
dollars for your city i think that's a
good idea he's simple reigning champion
yeah
what
the amount of money he makes is more
than the amount of money you make not
even not only yourself for society yes
but you need the city the city needs it
is what i'm trying to say [ __ ] him and
the money he makes there are people
whose jobs rely on him coming into the
town and making that tournament happen
right right like think about the amount
of money they're going to lose like a
buddy of ours
he works in the league and uh you know
they were supposed to have a game uh
that they ended up shutting down
and it works for the raptors right and
he was supposed to have a game that
they're gonna end up shutting down was
against the warriors they're gonna lose
five million dollars
like that's what you end up losing in
that situation because i think this is
when toronto said we have to shut down
everybody no capacity it's not even half
capacity no capacity five million bucks
and you literally gotta call the leading
day yo call the [ __ ] city or call the
uh the province or whatever it is and be
like can we push this two more days
we're about to lose five million dollars
and they go no they don't get a flying
[ __ ] about it and also can you imagine
how much extra money and ratings on tv
that this controversy is going to get
because every novak game everyone who
loves him and has got to love him more
because he's anti-vax and he's standing
up for what is right in his opinion and
all that yeah they're all going to be
like we're tuning in and he's also now a
villain that everyone else will be like
i want to see them get knocked out yeah
they'll be the highest viewed tennis
games
you